la crise sanitaire en france on en
parlait en titre le pire est dernière
nous l'optimisme affiché d'olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé qui
revenu hier sur la situation sanitaire
en france le pic de contamination de la
cinquième vague franchi les restrictions
sanitaires pour s alléger
considérablement fin du port du masque à
l'intérieur au printemps et même
suppression du pass vaccinale avant
juillet si l'évolution de l'épidémie
bien sûr le père mais antoine logié
il a fait l'objet de manifestations
massives et de discussions interminables
au parlement avant d'être finalement
adopté le 22 janvier dernier il dix
jours plus tard le pass vaccinale
approche déjà de son obsolescence il
pourrait ne plus être réclamés nulle
part avant juillet mais sous certaines
conditions je pense que nous devons
donner la visibilité et la lisibilité
aux français cet outil du pass vaccinale
qui est un début qui a une fin
aujourd'hui la fin on la connaît c'est
dans la loi c'est juillet mais si nous
pouvons supprimer le passage final avant
nous le ferons quand on aura vidé l'erea
si vous permettez l'expression en tout
cas rendu la place aux malades qui
relèvent normalement de la réanimation
et qu'il n'y aura plus un point des
programmes et dans notre pays s'il n'y a
pas de nouveaux variants circulation à
ce moment là l'utilité du paf actional
sera totalement discutable et nous
pourrons leur retirer un changement de
cap que le ministre de la santé justifie
par la baisse notable du nombre de
contaminations et d'hospitalisations
liées aux qu'ovide 2000 personnes
hospitalisées en moins entre hyères et
la semaine dernière et une moyenne des
contaminations qui a baissé de 60 milles
sur les sept derniers jours un tiers des
30 2700 patients hospitalisés en ce
moment le serait pour d'autres raisons
que le coc vide
interrogé sur d'autres changements à
venir olivier vers ans évoque un
assouplissement des conditions
d'obtention du pass une infection
équivaudra désormais à une injection à
condition d'avoir reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin pour bénéficier du pass il
faut qu'on a été exposée que notre
système immunitaire a été stimulée trois
fois au moins trois fois une stimulation
ça peut être une injection de vaccin ou
ça peut être une affection et qu'au
minimum il faut avoir reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin pour renforcer l'immunité
des propos qui ont aussitôt fait réagir
l'opposition
tout ce charabia ville simplement
retirer le certificat de rétablissement
et à vous obliger à faire au moins une
dose une rupture dans le mauvais sens
vers en est absolument rien d'autre que
le vrp de father je continuerai à faire
sans aucun passe
concernant la vaccination pour les
enfants de moins de cinq ans celle ci ne
serait pas à l'ordre du jour mais le
gouvernement n'exclut pas qu'une dose de
rappel soit obligatoire à l'automne en
fonction de l'évolution de la pandémie
selon les derniers chiffres du ministère
de la santé au moins un français sur
deux aurait eu le coc vie depuis le
début de l'épidémie tandis que 15
millions de personnes auraient été
touchées par le vario omicron
et le ministre de la santé qui laisse
donc entendre que le pass vaccinale
pourrait être levée dès l'été des
déclarations qui moins de quinze jours
avant l'entrée en vigueur des
dispositifs n'ont pas manqué d'en agacer
certains alors la stratégie sanitaire
gouvernementale est elle devenue
purement politique on en parle avec vous
et eric revel éditorialistes rt france
merci d'être avec nous tout d'abord
olivier verrons qui s'est vraiment la
confusion avec ces histoires de doses
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à y voir clair
est-ce que vous avez compris quelque
chose alors je vais vous dire j'ai
écouté j'ai réécouté le ministre de la
santé parce que c'est un personnage
important depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire ses explications sont rui pour
le moins très confuse 1 si on peut
résumer les choses on s'aperçoit qu'il
faut une dose avec deux infections par
exemple deux doses avec une infection
donc en fait on nage me semble-t-il en
plein délire et cette sortie du ministre
de la santé non seulement va jeter le
trouble sur ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés aujourd'hui mais va également
et c'est mon cas semer le doute sur ceux
qui sont déjà vaccinés par pourquoi pas
parce qu'on vous explique que si vous
avez été contaminé deux fois une seule
dose aurait suffi alors pourquoi est ce
que le gouvernement depuis le début pour
obtenir y est le fameux pass sanitaire
puis le pass vaccinale nous a obligés à
faire trois doses donc ça devient un
sujet de santé me semble-t-il peut-être
que le gouvernement et le ministre de la
santé aura à un moment donné à rendre
des comptes sur ce type de déclaration
mais ça devient aussi un psy j'ai
politique parce qu'on voit bien que tout
se toutes ses déclarations sur la crise
sanitaire il faut les les replonger les
remettent dans le contexte politique du
moment et de la campagne électorale dans
laquelle emmanuel macron n'est toujours
pas candidat à ce stade pourquoi je dis
ça parce que quand le ministre de la
santé ajoute que si tout va bien que si
tout va bien on pourrait suspendre le
pass vaccinale avant le mois de juillet
je vous rappelle combats d'avril il ya
des élections présidentielles et je
pense sans vouloir faire de procès à
quiconque mais les hommes politiques
restent des hommes politiques et le
temps politique est compté pour emmanuel
macron je pense que tout cela au delà la
confusion de la déclaration du ministre
vers ans s'inscrit évidemment dans une
communication politique qui va être la
mise en orbite un moment donné des
manuels mâcon comme candidat alors je
vous rassure enchère eric revel vous
n'êtes pas le seul à voir voilà soulevé
quelques petites interrogations vous
propose d'écouter aujourd'hui bernard
jomier 1 le sénateur socialiste
justement à porter un du coc u19 aux os
énerve à part à porter de bref on aura
compris écouter eric sommier
toutes les auditions menées ces derniers
temps montrent que le pass vaccinale
n'est pas un bon outil de gestion de
l'épidémie c'est donc un outil politique
choisir le pass vaccinale plutôt que
l'obligation vaccinale avec la mise en
oeuvre de politiques de conviction et de
contrainte est un choix politique
la levée sera déterminée par des choix
politiques je pense donc que dans les
semaines à venir avant l'élection
présidentielle
le gouvernement utilisera la levée du
pass vaccinale comme un outil politique
voilà le rapporteur de la mission comme
il a 19 au sénat eric revel est-ce que
emmanuel macron ils ne bénéficient pas
tout simplement d'un bon timing c'est
vrai que l'homme au micro dé moins
dangereux
voilà le printemps arrive on peut lui
laisser le bénéfice du doute
éventuellement bien sûr on peut lui
laisser le bénéfice du tout dit-il en
souriant légèrement mais ce que je
remarque le bon timing en question c'est
un timing qui est cousue
à dessein pour permettre me semble t'il
au chef de l'état de rentrer en campagne
regardez un autre type de confusion qui
est passée un peu inaperçue mais qui
comme absolument incroyable on continue
même si on sait que le virus mikron est
plus virulent mais moins létales on
continue d'avoir jour après jour des
centaines de milliers de personnes
contaminées pendant des semaines on nous
a expliqué que les contraintes
sanitaires devaient être absolument mis
sur la table et respecté parce que on ne
maîtrisait pas cette vague de micron et
bien c'est pourtant le moment que
choisit le gouvernement pour desserrer
la plupart des contraintes sanitaires il
ya plus de jauge dans les stades il ya
plus de masques à l'extérieur donc deux
choses l'une ou bien la vague était
inquiétant avant il fallait garder ce
pass sanitaire vaccinale avec des
mesures contraignantes ou bien ça ne
l'était pas mais comment expliquer aux
français que ce qui a prévalu il ya
encore quelques semaines n'est plus bon
aujourd'hui comment avec une vague qui
continue de montrer des centaines de
milliers d'oeufs contaminés on dessert
tout à coup les contraintes sanitaires
la raison peut-être peut-être si j'étais
un peu cynique 7 peut-être que him and
mail vaqueront macron veut apparaître
comme le sauveur au moment où il va
chanter dans la campagne donc moins de
contraintes plus de passes vaccinale
sans doute avant juillet une partie de
l'électorat da peut-être se dire le
sauveur c'était manuel makarov qui a
quelques médecins qui font entendre leur
voix ici ou là la plupart d'entre eux
désapprouvent la levée de ces
restrictions à ce niveau de circulation
quotidienne du virus il est évident que
des formes graves et malheureusement des
patients qui vont décéder seront et sont
nombreuses sont les mots par exemple du
chef du service réanimation de l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches dans les
hauts-de-seine et ce n'est pas le seul
ça ce n'est pas une faute morale on sait
qu'il ya d'autres ministres qui auront
fini devant la cour de justice de la
république
quand il s'agit de santé publique est ce
qu'on peut se permettre de faire de la
politique il ne devrait pas se permettre
de faire de la politique quand il s'agit
de la santé collective quand il s'agit
de la santé d'une nation tout entière
maintenant on peut quand même admettre
une chose c'est que depuis le début de
cette épidémie puisque cette épidémie
était nouvelle même si les coronavirus
n'étaient pas des inconnus on sait que
les coronavirus les spécialistes disent
c'est pas moi il mute régulièrement donc
les mutations et les variantes
coronavirus c'est un peu inscrits
j'allais dire dans les gènes de ce type
de virus alors on peut dire que le
gouvernement parce que n'oubliez pas une
chose c'est que le principe de
précaution est inscrit dans la
constitution française depuis jacques
chirac que ce principe de au nom ce
principe de précaution le gouvernement a
voulu prendre le maximum de précautions
pour protéger le peuple français devant
une épidémie qu'on ne connaissait pas
donc on ne maîtrisait pas mais depuis
deux ans mais depuis deux ans on a quand
même le sentiment on en discute les uns
les autres on a quand même le sentiment
qu'on est un peu baladé au gré de cette
épidémie alors ceux qui dénoncent ce
genre d'attitude confuse sont traités de
complotiste bon très bien mais il ya
aussi plein de gens qui de bonne foi se
souviennent mais ils ont droit d'avoir
de la mémoire de tout le discours
politique qui était mise en place en
france depuis deux ans qui ne correspond
plus aux qui correspond de moins en
moins à la réalité que l'on vit au
quotidien et je pense que il faut quand
même faire attention politiquement parce
que emmanuel macron peut apparaître
comme le sauveur celui qui aura de
redonner sa liberté au peuple français
après l'avoir contraint avec des mesures
sanitaires mais l'agacement et la
confusion dont on parlait tout à l'heure
avec olivier ferrand peuvent au
contraire créer une sorte de bulle de
mécontentement qui pourrait le moment
venu venu au mois d'avril se traduire
dans les urnes quand même une remarque
il ya près de 569 me français qui
auraient perdu à l'heure pas sanitaire
samedi faute d'une troisième dose ce qui
n'est pas là aussi le problème c'est que
les français n'adhèrent plus quand on
leur explique qu mikron voilà n'est pas
très dangereux
le vaccin est résistant face à ce
variant
ça mais le gouvernement devant ses
contradictions oui c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est à dire que on peut
apparaître comme le sauveur c'est
peut-être là dessus que que table
emmanuel macron pour sa future
candidature mais il y a aussi de plus en
plus de français semble-t-il qui portent
un jugement très critique sur la méthode
sur la stratégie qui a été suivi hélas
la seule explication qui est de dire on
ne connaissait pas on ne pouvait pas
savoir est de moins en moins suffisante
pour expliquer les tâtonnements où la
confusion après j'ai entendu olivier
veyrat stéphanie je veux dire au début
je me suis dit c'est une sorte de fait
que news c'est peut-être quelqu'un qui
imite olivier ferrand mais pas du tout
mais pas du tout il a expliqué d'un ton
docte des choses extrêmement compliquée
qui à mon sens remettait en cause une
grande partie de la stratégie que le
gouvernement nous a obligé à suivre dans
ce pays depuis des semaines et des mois
ça va suivre dans les écoles aussi
jean michel blanquer re va être
réhabilité c'est vrai que l'on parle de
lever les restrictions également dans
les écoles c'est un sujet également oui
bien sûr c'est un sujet parce que on a
tous des enfants où on a tous des dd des
connaissances qui ont qui ont des
enfants c'est devenu quand même alors
j'ai employée la formule est
irrespirable pour beaucoup d'écoliers de
collégiens ou des lycéens de continuer à
devoir porter un masque souvenez-vous ce
qu'on avait dit on avait dit les jeunes
sont à quelques exceptions près
malheureusement pas touché directement
par cette épidémie mais ce sont des
sujets qui transporte le virus alors le
gouvernement on peut dire on n'a pas
fermé les écoles c'est une grande
victoire mais le jour où on va permettre
aux enfants dans ce pays d'enlever le
masque ça va être une libération
absolument incroyable n'oubliez pas que
quand vous apprenez à lire le fait de ne
pas avoir votre institutrice outre
instituteur prononcé des mots parce
qu'il a un masque c'est un handicap
sérieux pour l'apprentissage de la
lecture sans parler de la contrainte
formelle qui est d'imposer un enfant
huit ans de 7 ans de 10 ans de 15 ans le
port du masque donc tout cela je pense
espérons le va sauter dans quelques dans
quelques jours dans quelques semaines
mais l'heure du bilan viendra alors
est-ce qu'il viendra après l'élection
présidentielle je pense que c'est le
souhait d' emmanuel macron ps qui
deviendra avant c'est le souhait de
l'opposition et du tout les candidats
qui se présentent face à emmanuel macron
merci beaucoup eric revel pour ce
décryptage merci